henry lau is thriving he is taking no
prisoners he's not landing anyone
breathe anytime soon yeah I don't take
any prisoners hi this is henry lau i'm
here at BuzzFeed and I'm gonna be
reading a bunch of thirst tweets what if
it's like really bad stuff this sexy
lips I just want to kiss him now XD
Henry why are you so cute
or what's the error thank you yeah i i'm
glad you you like my lips yeah there's
my lips okay so far so good
henry looks so damn hot when his whole
body is soaked when have you seen my
body so baby please you are so handsome
hot please calm down okay
no love you what calm down I know I'm
hot calm down Henry is such a fluff ball
I fluff ball would it I've always wanted
to ask what part of me is fluffy I don't
think I'm fluffy but thank you where
does he come up with these these these
ideas shake the world with his amazing
violin performance Henry is so genius I
actually brought my violin
[Music]
in case you didn't know this is henry
lau AKA my biggest musician inspiration
in this whole world he's like a god to
me and I love him with my life thank you
you're so sweet you beautiful creature
you yeah I'm happy to be here
your beautiful creature he's perfect
boyfriend material because he is true
gentleman so nice and sweet where most
boys are mean and rude I hope you don't
meet more mean and rude guys as you're
an amazing person I will continue to be
your boyfriend material why babe you so
hot you know I was trapped by you
it's referring to my song trapped now
I'm losing it I'm trapped I'm trapped
trapped in you help I've fallen in love
with Henry Lau WTF put Wyatt WTF oh my
god Henry's so sexy look at his eye
thank you for thinking my eye is sexy
not my eyes in my eye I guess that's it
there's no more thank you guys all so
much for thinking my eye is sexy I think
I'm a fluff ball I love you guys you
guys mean the world to me I should do
this more
[Music]